PRESENTER: All right.
Welcome, everyone.
Really thrilled to be
hosting Barry Strauss today
for our Authors@ series
in Mountain View.
Barry is a professor
of history and classics
at Cornell University,
and he's the author
of seven books on ancient
history and military,
and a naval historian
and consultant.
For the spring semester, he is
a visiting scholar at the Hoover
Institution at Stanford.
In his book "Masters
of Command,"
Barry compares the
way the three greatest
generals in the ancient world--
Alexander, Hannibal,
and Caesar--
waged war and draw lessons
from the experiences that apply
on and off the battlefields.
Understanding where each of
these three great but flawed
commanders succeeded
and failed concerns
anyone who wants to
think strategically
or must demonstrate leadership.
And with that, I'll
turn it over to Barry.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
BARRY STRAUSS: Thank you,
Jessica, and thanks, everyone.
It's really great to be here.
And as Jessica said, I'm going
to talk about leadership.
I often talk about
leadership, and I'm always
excited to see how passionate
people are about the subject.
I want to talk about
what makes a great leader
and how leaders
inspire and motivate
people to give their best.
But I also want to talk
about what kind of leaders
we need today.
And to get to that subject, I'm
going to start with the past.
I'm going to take a
historical approach.
Now I know that
Henry Ford famously
said that history is bunk.
And I also know
that I'm going to be
speaking about ancient history.
So perhaps what I'm going to
be doing today is double bunk.
But I hope that I
can persuade you
that there are some things
about the human condition that
haven't changed and
from which we can learn.
Let me tell you that my
methodology as a historian
is fairly traditional.
I think my perspective is
broad, but my methodology
is traditional.
And my approach, to some
extent, is storytelling.
My notion of leadership
is looking at leadership
as an art rather than a science,
although there are certainly
scientific approaches
that one could take.
And my intention is to
raise some broad questions.
So in looking at Alexander
the Great, Hannibal, Julius
Caesar--
and today, I'm going to
add a fourth person who
is very much part of the story.
That's Cleopatra.
So in looking at
these leaders, I
want to talk about what I call
the paradox of leadership,
or what I also call the
problem of Alexander
and the cup of water.
And I'll explain
what I mean by that.
More generally, I
think I want to ask
the question is it better
to have a leader who
is charismatic or caring?
Is it better to have a leader
who is strong or humble?
And is it possible to have both?
Can we have our cake
and eat it, too?
Can we have a leader who is
both charismatic and caring?
Well, those are some of the
questions I want to ask today.
Now, if you think
about these names--
I'm sure you've heard of them
before-- on the face of it,
it might seem absurd
to suggest that they
could be caring or humble.
After all, folks like
Alexander and Caesar
are exhibit A of power and
ego and the blind spots
those qualities can create.
These are certainly leaders
who issued top-down orders.
And yet the closer
we look at them,
the more we see that they
didn't simply issue commands,
and they weren't
simply top down.
These were leaders who led by
example, who considered others
in the group, and who also
offered outstanding benefits.
So let me say a little
bit about each of them,
just as an overview
to begin with.
So Alexander, whose dates
are 359 to 323 B.C.,
he is the king of
Macedon, and he goes on
to conquer an empire.
He conquers the greatest
empire that the world had
known to date, and that
was the Persian Empire.
It stretched about 3,000
miles from the Mediterranean
to South Asia.
And it included, perhaps, about
20% of the people on Earth.
Alexander conquered this
empire, and he employed a series
of disruptive paradigms.
First, he won a
naval war on land.
And second, having
conquered the empire,
he then proceeded to attempt to
create a new ruling class that
would consist of intermarriage
between Greeks and Macedonia
on the one hand and
Iranians on the other.
It was something that
neither group took to easily.
And Alexander-- whether this
experiment would have succeeded
or not, we don't know,
because Alexander died young.
And he left behind a legacy
of civil war and disruption.
His new empire did not last.
With Hannibal, we're going
down to the next century.
He's born in 247
B.C., dies in 183.
He is a Carthaginian
who, from a base
in a colonial empire in
southern Spain, invades Italy.
And he does so-- again,
another disruptive paradigm--
by shocking his Roman
opponents by marching 900 miles
overland from southern
Spain across the Pyrenees,
southern France, the
Rhone, and then the Alps,
and drops down into
northern Italy.
He takes with him an
army and 37 elephants,
who he famously manages to get
across the Alps in the snow,
and then invade Italy.
He then proceeds to hand the
Romans the biggest military
defeats that they had
ever had, including
one of the most lopsided
victories in history,
the Battle of Cannae, in 216
BCE, in which Hannibal's army
defeats an enemy army that's
about twice the size of his,
and in which he carries out
one of the gold standards
of tactical achievement
on the battlefield--
a double envelopment,
something that's
bedeviled people over the
ages, or bewitched people
over the ages.
He and his army last
in Italy for 15 years.
He never has a
mutiny, which is very
unusual for ancient conditions.
But he goes on to lose the war.
In spite of his great victories,
in the end, he is defeated,
and his own country
suffers the fate
that he expected Rome to suffer.
The third case is Julius Caesar.
His dates are 100 to 44 B.C.
Caesar was a great conqueror.
His goals were first
to conquer an empire
for the Republic, his
soldiers, and himself,
not necessarily in that
order, and then to take on--
he conquerors and
empire in Gaul,
and then to take on the
entire Roman ruling elite,
and to bend it to his will,
which he proceeds to do.
He, too, uses
disruptive paradigms.
He invades Italy against
the entire Roman state
with only 5,000 men behind him.
And in his climactic battle--
Battle of Pharsalus
in Greece in 48 B.C.--
he manages to defeat cavalry
by a very unusual infantry
tactic--
sending infantry to stop
cavalry dead in their tracks.
Well, after all these conquests,
he lets success go to his head.
And he is the victim of one of
the most famous and greatest
conspiracies in history--
the conspiracy of
the Ides of March.
60 Romans, including a
majority of them Caesar's
own supporters, turn on him.
They stab him to death
in the Senate house
and bring down the
curtain very dramatically
on his most
extraordinary career.
Finally, Cleopatra--
Cleopatra was queen of Egypt.
Her dates were 69 to 30 B.C.,
so she, too, died young.
She was a descendant of one
of Alexander's generals,
a Macedonian.
And she came from
a ruling house that
had been ruling Egypt
for several centuries.
She herself did not
have the throne.
The throne had gone to
one of her brothers.
And she managed to maneuver
herself to be in a position
to become the queen
of Egypt, to defeat
her brother who
was on the throne
militarily, and then to--
he dies in battle--
then to get rid of
another brother,
and indeed, to get
rid of her sister.
She was quite ruthless, but
she was a brilliant strategist,
exceedingly charming.
And she managed to
get on her side,
in turn, two of the
strongest men in Rome--
first Julius Caesar,
whose lover she became.
And she bore a son, who she
claimed was Caesar's son.
And then Mark Antony.
After Caesar is
assassinated, she
becomes his mistress
and then his wife
and bears three children to him.
She almost succeeds in
having the power of Rome
move eastward to the capital
of Egypt, to Alexandria.
And she almost succeeds in
shifting the balance of power,
in making Egypt independent,
in bringing Rome over to Egypt.
And she influences
both Caesar and Antony
and their conceptions.
Huge influence on
Caesar and on his notion
of what it means, what he's
going to do-- having conquered
Rome, how is he
going to govern Rome,
and what is he going to
do with the city of Rome.
He gets a lot of his
ideas from Cleopatra,
from seeing her
success as a queen
and seeing what her dynasty
had achieved in Alexandria
as the capital city of Egypt.
Antony also looks
eastward with Cleopatra,
opening a vision of conquest
to empire in the East for him.
In the end, it doesn't work.
They come up against
a greater talent.
Octavian becomes Augustus,
Rome's first emperor.
But for a moment, it
looks as if Cleopatra
was going to be the most
powerful woman in human history
to that date.
With that as a
historical overview,
let me say a little bit
about my model of leadership
and the paradox of leadership.
So on the one hand, we
have very strong leaders.
And these leaders
all have in common
a certain series
of characteristics
that they project.
They project strength.
They project intelligence.
They project passion, energy,
and communication skills.
And in particular, each of them
has a very powerful brand--
a brand that's simple,
identifiable, and compelling.
They also have a
persuasive mission.
So it's the combination of
the brand and the mission
that makes their
communication successful.
Now, all of these
qualities are ones
that they could use by
leading from the top.
They're all top-down qualities.
But there's another
set of qualities
that they have that
are not so top down.
And these are
leading by example,
sharing hardships, minimizing
risk to their best performers,
building community, and
offering outstanding benefits.
These are all part of what
these leaders did as well.
So let's take a closer
look at how this works.
Alexander the Great first.
Here is an image of Alexander.
This is a Roman mosaic, a famous
mosaic that comes from Pompeii.
And it projects Alexander as
he wanted people to see him.
You can see that
he is in battle.
He's in battle against
his Persian opponent.
He is on horseback.
If you look at the
guy behind him,
you'll see that the
fellow behind him
is wearing a helmet, which of
course Alexander would have
been doing as well in battle.
He wouldn't have gone into
battle without a helmet.
But the artist is
taking license here
that's very much part of
Alexander's public image
of someone who is fearless.
He is someone who is young.
Greek men-- mature
Greek men-- wore beards.
But he is beardless, so
he's emphasizing his youth.
And you'll also notice his
hair is parted in the middle
and it is swept back.
It's windblown.
This is the image that
Alexander liked to present.
Now, yes, here he is
in a leadership role
going fearlessly in to battle.
But he's also somebody
who saw himself
very much as a caring leader
and someone who paid attention
to his men.
This is the story of Alexander
and the cup of water.
At one point during
his long journey
eastward conquering
the Persian Empire,
he found himself in what
is today Afghanistan.
And Alexander was leading
his army northwards
through the desert in what is
today northern Afghanistan.
It's an area of desert.
The men were running
out of water.
They were in terrible shape.
And let me read to you from
one of the ancient sources what
Alexander does.
"These urgent problems
distressed Alexander.
His friends stood
around him and begged
him to remember that
his intrepid spirit was
all that could
restore the fortunes
of his languishing army.
At this point, he was met by
two of the men who'd gone ahead
to select the campsite.
They're carrying skins
of water to bring relief
to their sons,
who they knew were
suffering from severe thirst
in Alexander's column.
On meeting the king,
one of them opened
a skin, filled the
cup he was carrying,
and offered it to him.
Alexander took it.
Then he asked for whom they
were carrying the water
and learned it was
for their sons.
He returned the cup, as full
as it was when it was offered
to him, saying I cannot
bear to drink alone,
and it is not possible for me to
share so little with everybody.
Go quickly and give
your sons what you
have brought on their account."
So after this gesture
of self-abnegation,
that very evening,
they come to a river.
They can all drink.
And Alexander waits until
everyone in his army drinks.
He's the last one to
take a drink of water.
Did it really happen this way?
Does it matter?
It's the message that
Alexander gave out.
It's the image that he wanted
to people to have of him--
as I said, a caring leader.
Here's another
image of Alexander.
This is a coin issued
in his lifetime.
You can see
Alexander's head here.
And he is wearing the lion's
skin of Heracles or Hercules.
He Identifies himself with
this great Greek hero,
this great Greek warrior,
a symbol of strength,
but also the son of Zeus,
the king of the gods.
We see Zeus on the
other side of the coin.
You can see that it says the
coin belongs to Alexander.
And Alexander proclaimed
himself as the son of Zeus.
He proclaimed himself
as no less than a god.
This outraged some of his
subjects but delighted others.
Because for them, being the
son of a god was, in some ways,
equivalent to us
being a celebrity,
being somebody who really
deserved great fame.
There are other ways as
well in which Alexander
showed that he was caring.
He visited the sick
in military hospitals.
He took very good care
of widows and orphans.
He set up statues back
in the home country
to officers who
had died in battle.
And he certainly led by example.
More than any of the other
people we're talking about,
he liked to lead
in the front lines.
In fact, he fought in
the front lines too much.
During his battles, Alexander
suffered seven major battle
wounds, one of which
almost killed him.
And it might be the reason
why he succumbed just
before his 33rd
birthday to a virus.
If he hadn't had this
series of wounds beforehand,
he might have been
in better shape.
He was a workaholic.
And he said that only the
need for sleep and sex
reminded him that he was human.
Well, he was human.
And as I said, he
died at the age of 33
while he was planning
to lead his army
on to yet more conquests, having
conquered the Persian Empire.
He intended to conquer Arabia
and Carthage and then Italy.
So let's move on to Hannibal.
We don't have a
coin of Hannibal,
at least one that we
can securely identify
as belonging to Hannibal.
This coin is probably issued
by his father, Hamilcar,
who was also a great commander.
But it touches the same
themes that Hannibal
touches in his propaganda.
And we know that Hannibal
uses these themes
because the written
sources talk about them.
So on one side of the coin,
the face we're looking at
is, by now, our old
friend Heracles, Hercules.
He's got a victory
wreath, and he
is carrying a club,
another symbol of Hercules.
Hercules is important
for Hannibal
because he is also the first
god of the ancient world
to go to Spain, to go from
the Eastern Mediterranean
all the way to Spain.
Hannibal has his base in Spain.
Hannibal is a Carthaginian.
They worship Hercules
in their own form.
They call him Melqart.
But it's roughly the same god.
They have a temple of Hercules
that they build on the Atlantic
Ocean, because they're
so excited about the fact
that they're so intrepid--
they've gone all the way
from the Mediterranean
to the Atlantic.
And according to myth,
Hercules, after going to Spain,
goes back towards
Greece by way of Italy
and has some conquests
in Italy as well.
So he's a symbol of
Hannibal and how Hannibal
plans to conquer Italy.
He's Hannibal's
brand, as it were.
If Alexander's brand
was youth and charisma,
Hannibal's brand is
Hercules and the elephant.
And here you see the elephant
on the other side of the coin.
Now, why the elephant?
The Carthaginians acquired
elephants in Africa
and brought them with them
to Spain, and then, indeed,
to Italy.
But the paradox-- and
they use them in war.
But the paradox is that they
didn't use them very much.
The elephants were more terror
weapons than anything else.
They were more
symbols than they were
practical realities in battle.
In fact, elephants are of
so little use in battle
that one of my
colleagues says there's
a simple rule to
ancient battle--
the side that has the most
elephants always loses.
But the elephant was a really
good symbol for Hannibal.
The elephant is a symbol
of strength, of heroism,
of intelligence-- because
elephants are very intelligent
animals--
of emotion, because elephants
are easily aroused to emotion,
and of rebellion, because
elephants are hard to control.
It's a symbol that Hannibal
goes back to again and again.
He makes sure that he's
seen riding on elephants
in the Italian countryside.
He makes sure that he's
seen entering on elephants
when he enters cities.
And even though he's very
short on supplies in Italy,
he has his home base in
Carthage send nine elephants
across the Mediterranean.
It's so important to
him that he has these
to intimidate the opposition.
Now, if Alexander's mission
was a mission of revenge
and conquest, Hannibal's
mission is a mission
of revenge and liberation.
When he comes to Italy,
he says he is not there
to conquer the
Italians, but rather,
to liberate the Italians
from the yoke of Rome.
Italy for the
Italians is his motto.
And he uses it again and again
to try to wean away allies
from Rome and wean them over to
the side of the Carthaginians.
And he offers these allies
extremely generous terms
in order to get their support.
He's successful to a degree,
though not, ultimately,
to the degree that
would allow him to win.
He depends, above all, on the
army he's brought with him
and on the
reinforcements he gets.
It's a remarkable army.
It is one of the most
multi-ethnic armies
in the ancient world.
It is surely the most
multi-ethnic professional army
that the ancient world has seen.
It consists of people
from North Africa--
both Carthaginians, Libyans,
and people of Berber descent
as well as Numidians--
that is to say,
the equivalent of
Algerians today.
It consists of people from
Spain, mostly Celt Iberians.
It consists of Celts
from Northern Italy.
And it consists of Greeks and
Semites and Oscan speakers,
a variety of people from
Southern Italy, All of whom
join Hannibal.
How does he hold them together?
Well, one of the ways that
he holds them together
is through his ability
to lead by example.
Let me read a quotation.
"There was no leader in whom the
soldiers placed more confidence
or under whom they
showed more daring.
He was fearless in
exposing himself to danger
and perfectly self-possessed
in its presence.
No amount of exertion could
cause him either bodily
or mental fatigue.
He was equally indifferent
to heat and cold.
His eating and
drinking were measured
by the needs of nature,
not by appetite.
His hours of sleep were not
determined by day or night.
Whatever time was not
taken up with active duties
was given to sleep and rest.
But that rest was not wooed
on a soft couch or in silence.
Men often saw him
lying on the ground
amongst the sentinels
and outposts, wrapped
in his military cloak.
His dress was in no way superior
to that of his comrades.
What did make him conspicuous
were his arms and horses.
He was by far the foremost,
both of the cavalry
and the infantry, the first to
enter the fight and the last
to leave the field.
So he was indeed someone
who led by example.
He's also someone
who takes great care
to minimize the risks
that his best men share.
So his best soldiers--
the elite ones
from North Africa--
he is very sparing
of and only uses them
in the most necessary
situations, otherwise
using other soldiers.
He himself, like Alexander,
shares hardships and suffers
with the men.
While he is leading the
army over the mountains
from Northern to
Central Italy, they
have to go through a
very difficult swamp.
It's extremely unhealthy.
He gets an infection in
his eye, and the infection
leads to permanent
negative effects.
He loses sight in
one of his eyes.
He's willing to take
this kind of risk
and suffer this kind
of loss for the cause.
It has a great effect on
his followers, particularly
the Celts.
Because the Celts believed
that one of their gods
was a one-eyed god.
And they came to associate
Hannibal with this one-eyed god
and saw him, like
that God, as someone
who was leading to victory.
Hannibal also has
a sense of humor.
We're told that before
the Battle of Cannae, when
one of his officers saw that
the Romans outnumbered them
by two to one, he said he was
terrified at the amazing army
that the Romans
had put together.
And the man's name was Gizgo.
So Gizgo was terrified at
how amazing the army was.
And Hannibal replies to him,
it is an amazing army, Gizgo.
But I'll tell you one
thing I'm sure of--
there's no one in
it named Gizgo.
As I said, Hannibal
never suffers a mutiny.
Alexander does suffer a mutiny.
His men mutiny in India
and force him to turn back.
Hannibal is in Italy for 15
years, living off the land.
And yet his men
remain satisfied.
He pays them very
well, and he also
makes sure that they have
sufficient rest and recreation.
Let's turn to Gaius
Julius Caesar.
Here we see a statue of Caesar.
This is a statue in green slate.
It probably comes from Egypt.
It probably was carved
within the century
after Caesar's death.
If you look at it,
you can see this
is a statue that shows what
a lot of hard living this man
has done.
His cheeks are sunken.
He's got crow's feet.
He's got wrinkles.
His hairline is receding.
His look is certainly
not youthful and happy.
This is probably the
reality of the man
in the last years of his life.
We know that he was suffering
from epilepsy as well
as from a series
of mini-strokes,
so hardly in the peak of health.
But that's not the
image that Caesar wanted
to present to the Romans.
Here we have a coin that
was issued within a month
before his death.
So Caesar dies on March 15,
44 B.C. This coin probably
was issued in February.
And if you look at it, you
see this man looks vigorous.
He's looking straight ahead.
He is square-jawed.
He's wearing a victory wreath.
There's nothing of the tired,
old Caesar that we saw before.
And the legend is
Caesar Imperator,
Caesar the Victorious General.
This is the one of the images
he wanted the Romans to conceive
of himself.
Caesar's brand is victory,
but not just any victory.
It's victory won by
intelligence and speed.
And he comes up with one of
the most famous marketing
slogans in history--
veni, vidi, vici--
I came, I saw, I conquered.
He displays it in a
triumphal procession
through the heart
of Rome, which is
why I show this modern monument,
the Wedding Cake, as it's
sometimes called, the Altar
of the Fatherland in Italian.
You see the chariot
there on top.
And this monument stands on
the Capitoline Hill in Rome,
which is where Caesar's
triumphal procession would
have ended up.
I came, I saw, I conquered.
It's meant to be so
brief as to symbolize
the speed of Caesar's victory.
So Caesar was fighting a
rebel in what is today Turkey.
The father of this
rebel had been
one of the most problematic
enemies the Romans had ever
fought.
And it took them two
decades to defeat him.
Caesar defeats this
guy in one day.
And that's what he wants
everybody to remember.
I came, I saw, I conquered.
And indeed, his speed had
been one of his trademarks
throughout his military career.
He wants to terrify people
into accepting his power.
The funny thing about it is that
in addition to being a general,
Caesar is also a politician.
And as a politician, he
is the ancient equivalent
of a populist--
not entirely a populist.
He's certainly not
a man of the people.
As one of my colleagues
put it, Caesar neither
was nor is lovable.
He was very much an aristocrat.
And yet he built
his political career
on giving benefits to the
ordinary people of Rome,
of listening to the
ordinary people of Rome
and speaking to their needs.
So in that sense, he very
much was a populist as well as
being someone who
moved with great speed.
There are other
aspects in which Caesar
showed his care for ordinary
people besides his populism.
As a commander, he paid great
attention to the captains
in his army.
The senior officers
of the Roman army
were mostly there because
they were aristocrats,
they were nobles, and they
got these positions from pull.
The only reliable professional
officers in the Roman army
were the captains,
or the centurions,
as the Romans called them.
These were people who
came from the middle class
or the upper middle class.
And Caesar paid them a
great deal of attention.
Unlike other Roman generals,
he listened to the centurions
and what they had to say.
He welcomed them to
his councils of war.
He gave them a
seat at the table.
When Caesar writes
his famous propaganda
books about his wars, the
commentaries on the Gallic Wars
and the commentaries
on the Civil War,
he foregrounds the centurions.
In some ways, they were
the heroes of the show.
And they show how much
they think of Caesar
by later on offering him a
loan when he's very hard up
for funds.
Another way in which
Caesar shows his concern
for ordinary soldiers is he
honors them by calling them
fellow soldiers.
It may seem a small
thing, fellow soldiers.
But no Roman general had
ever done that before.
They always called
them soldiers.
He calls them fellow soldiers,
as if he were one of them.
And he certainly rewards
them financially.
He offers them enormous riches.
An ordinary legionary,
an ordinary soldier,
would get a bonus that was
2,500% of his annual wages.
A captain would
get a bonus that's
5,000% of his annual wages.
A colonel would get
a bonus that was
10,000% of his annual wages.
And as for the highest
officers, their benefits
were entirely off the charts.
That a sort of benefit
that encouraged people
to stay with Caesar
for a long time.
Again, if he's not a man
who was naturally lovable,
he yet was able to inspire
friendship, sometimes
by little gestures.
For instance, once on campaign,
one of Caesar's friends
was in very poor health.
They came to a place
to spend the night.
It was a small house, really
a hut with a front porch.
And Caesar insisted that his
friend stay inside the house
because he wasn't doing
well, whereas Caesar
slept on the front porch.
After his assassination,
one of Caesar's friends
wrote in a letter, "I
didn't follow the cause--"
in supporting Caesar--
"I didn't follow the cause.
I followed the man.
And I followed him
because he was my friend."
So Caesar was able
to inspire loyalty.
Caesar also did a very good job
in building a military culture
that inspired and rewarded
individual initiative.
It might seem paradoxical
that someone like Caesar--
who became a
dictator, after all--
Rome's first and only
dictator for life--
that someone like
that should inspire
in his individual
initiative, and yet he did.
And I want to read you a short
selection from his commentaries
on the Gallic Wars.
This is from a battle at the
beginning of the war, battle
in what is now in
Northeastern France,
when the Gauls suddenly
ambushed the Romans,
and they threatened to
conquer the Romans, who
were unprepared for them.
And Caesar tells the story--
typical Caesar
style-- he foregrounds
his own contribution.
And yet, as we'll see,
more complicated than that.
He says, I had to do
everything at once--
hoist the flag that was the
signal for running to arms,
sound the trumpet,
recall the men
from their work on
the fortifications,
bring back the men who had
gone further afield in search
of material for the
rampart, get the troops
into battle formation,
address the men,
give the signal for attack.
There was no time to
do most of these things
because the enemy
was almost on us.
But in this very
difficult situation,
two things helped us--
first, the knowledge and
experience of the soldiers.
Their training in
earlier battles
meant that they could
decide for themselves
what had to be done
without waiting to be told.
Second, the order I had given
to all the legionary commanders
that they must stay
with their legions
and not leave the work until
the fortification of our camp
was completed.
Because the enemy was so close
in advancing at such speed,
the commanders of the legions
did not wait for further orders
from me, but did what seemed
best on their own initiative.
Now, if Caesar--
after he had conquered
Rome, if Caesar had remembered
to consult ordinary people,
and if Caesar had remembered
his background in associating
with others outside of his
class and not simply looking
at himself, he
might have avoided
his fate of being assassinated.
But he did not.
And fairly or
unfairly, the Romans
blame Caesar's fate, in
part, on this person, who
will be the last person
we'll look at today,
and that is Cleopatra.
Now, Cleopatra was
queen of Egypt,
but she was also the
mistress of Julius Caesar.
Julius Caesar had a very
active extracurricular life,
but none was more famous of his
various loves than Cleopatra.
Here we see two busts
of them in Berlin.
And if you look more closely
at the bust of Cleopatra--
this is one of the images that
she presented of herself--
it's actually quite
important because it
makes her look like a Greek
woman or a Roman woman.
It's kind of a standard
image of the time.
But her hairstyle
is very striking.
If you noticed, her hair
is pulled back in a bun
at the nape of her neck.
And in the front, she has
ringlets on her forehead.
This is a style that swept Rome.
It became one of the most
popular hairstyles of the day--
so much so that--
as I said, she becomes
an enemy of Octavian--
so much so that Octavian's
sister and his wife developed
their own counter-hairstyle
to oppose to Cleopatra's.
She's also wearing
the Ribbon of Royalty.
You can see it around her head.
The ancients wore ribbons
rather than crowns.
She looks like a
very serious person.
She is attractive, but
perhaps not beautiful.
Here's another
image of Cleopatra.
This is a coin image.
The hairstyle is
similar, and she is
wearing the Ribbon of Royalty.
But in this image,
she's projecting
an image that is certainly not
one of conventional beauty.
In fact, as you can see, she's
got a prominent nose and also
a very prominent chin.
And on her neck, she might have
a goiter, the site of a thyroid
condition.
She certainly could have
presented herself more
attractively if she had wanted.
Why did she do it this way?
Possibly because this is
what she really looked like
and she wanted people
to recognize her,
but possibly because
she wanted to recall
images of her father, who
had been king of Egypt.
And she wanted to
say, in effect,
I am my father's daughter.
Although it is not usual for the
ruler of Egypt to be a woman,
I'm entirely up to the job and
no less capable than any man.
Now, as I said,
Cleopatra was extremely
intelligent and capable of
doing things differently.
She is the first and
only ruler of Egypt
that we know of-- first and
only Greek ruler of Egypt--
who spoke Egyptian.
She's the only one to do so.
She certainly
wasn't the first who
knew how important
it was to appeal
to her Egyptian subjects.
But she went the extra step.
And I want to symbolize
that in this slide.
This is also an
image of Cleopatra.
Cleopatra-- this is
the Temple of Dendera
on the wall of the temple.
And he or she is with her son.
And as you can see,
Cleopatra shows herself
as very much an Egyptian woman.
She's not Greek.
She's not Roman.
She is Egyptian-- appealing
to her Egyptian subjects
and in a traditional
Egyptian pose.
This might have come
from the Pharonic period.
And she she's with her son.
Now, this is not an accident.
Her son is co-ruler with
her as Ptolemy the 15th.
That's the typical name of
the males of the dynasty.
But he also has a
nickname, and his nickname
is Caesarion, which
means little Caesar,
because she claimed that he
was Caesar's natural child.
Now, for her to present
herself with her son, I think,
is a strategy that's
not uncommon for women
leaders in the ancient world.
Certainly in the Roman
and the Egyptian world,
it's very difficult for a woman
to exercise power on her own
without having at least
symbols of male authority
where she can work with.
Very common in the Roman
Empire, for instance.
There are a series of
quite powerful women.
But they almost always
work through a man,
and ideally through their son.
In fact, there is a
great unwritten book
on Roman mothers and their sons.
Certainly there's work
been done on Roman mothers,
but I think there's
more to appreciate
just how close the mother-son
tie was in the Roman world
and how important
it was to power.
Caesar himself had a mother
of whom we know little.
Her name is Aurelia Cotta.
But she was a byword
for the Romans
of a mother who had
raised her son well
and had succeeded
in his education.
It's not at all surprising
that Cleopatra presents herself
in this way, with her son as
a way of making her subjects
see her as someone of
great authority and someone
who buttresses herself
with her son's image.
Cleopatra, alas, is also
not successful in the end.
Her attempt to work with Antony
to defeat their enemies in Rome
fails.
They are defeated at the
Naval Battle of Actium,
and she and Antony each
have to commit suicide--
romantically but tragically,
for their point of view.
So let me sum up what I have
to say about these leaders.
What are the lessons
that we have learned,
and what can the takeaways be?
Well, I want to go back to the
point that I mentioned earlier.
It's possible to
have leaders who are
both charismatic and caring.
It's possible to have leaders
who are strong but humble.
And I would suggest that
with Alexander, Hannibal,
and Caesar, and with
Cleopatra, we have just this.
They're strong,
they're intelligent,
they're personable, they're
passionate, they're energetic,
they are communicators
who have simple,
identifiable, compelling
brands and persuasive messages.
And yet they also
lead by example.
They share hardships.
They minimize the risks
of their best people.
They build a sense of community
and individual initiative.
And finally, they offer
outstanding benefits.
I hope those are the lessons
that you'll take away
from this look at these great
leaders of the ancient world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: Question for you.
So you mentioned that
a lot of the leaders
had a really innovative,
disruptive paradigms
and approaches to
their strategy.
What lessons can we take away
from any common qualities that
allowed for them
to be so innovative
and yet so seemingly in
touch with their people?
BARRY STRAUSS: Yeah, that's
really a great question.
I guess my first
answer is probably one
that maybe I shouldn't
think of as a teacher,
but not listening
to their teachers.
Alexander was famously taught
by Aristotle, the philosopher.
And I think he
learned from Aristotle
how to think, but also
not to necessarily think--
not necessarily
reached the conclusions
that Aristotle
wanted him to reach.
Aristotle was a great
thinker, but Aristotle
was quite an ethnic
chauvinist who
believed in the superiority
of Greek civilization
over any other civilization.
He believed that Greeks
were fit to be freemen,
and people who lived in Western
Asia were fit to be slaves.
Alexander didn't reach
that conclusion at all.
In fact, he wanted to create
a new ruling group that mixed
Greeks with Iranians.
So Aristotle wouldn't have
been pleased with that.
So one thing that they share
is when you go to school
learn how to think, but not
necessarily what to think.
And maybe that's one
lesson that we always
should be taking away-- looking
for the broader lessons,
looking for the paradigms
rather than the content.
Looks like we have a
question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for an interesting talk.
I think I'd like to
work with Hannibal.
He seemed the most interesting.
One of the leaders around
Silicon Valley that's fairly
well known is Steve Jobs.
Could you briefly compare
his leadership style
with that of the ancients?
BARRY STRAUSS: Well,
thanks for that question.
Steve Jobs has sometimes been
compared to Caesar, certainly
in his desire to build
something very big,
and also, I suppose,
in the sense
that he wasn't worried
about who he might offend.
He certainly wasn't shy
about saying what he thought.
Also, like any of
these commanders--
I hope I haven't left
you with the idea
that these commanders
were nice folks,
because they were ruthless.
And Steve Jobs was
certainly ruthless.
But I think all
three of them-- what
they share with
Steve Jobs is there's
a visionary quality
to what they did.
I think that Caesar
in particular
understood that the Roman
Republic was simply incapable
of dealing with
the Roman Empire.
The Romans had conquered
maybe 50 million people
at this point in history.
And yet the defenders
of the republic
thought that a few hundred
families, descended
from the Roman
nobility, could go
on governing 50 million people
around the Mediterranean world
without sharing power in any
meaningful way with this wider
group.
I think Caesar understood
that that was not acceptable
and that they really
needed to shift
the paradigm in massive ways.
It's one of the reasons why
he was so controversial,
and it's one of the reasons why
he gets killed-- because people
don't want to share power.
Likewise, Caesar was
ahead of his time--
perhaps not in such a good
way-- in that he believed
that monarchy was really
the only way to run Rome,
and that the Republic, which
was kind of ruled by committee,
was not something
that can continue.
Steve Jobs clearly is
also a visionary person.
And like Caesar, I think
he saw that people--
he saw something that
people needed before they
knew they needed it.
They shared that in common.
But you asked about Hannibal.
So a way in which Steve
Jobs is similar to Hannibal
is they both saw
themselves as liberators.
They both saw themselves
who were freeing people
and who were going to create
a better world in that sense.
Hannibal really didn't
want to destroy Rome.
He had no intention of
burning Rome to the ground.
He wanted the Romans to simply
agree to give up their power
and admit the fact
that they were beat
and that he had defeated them.
So he wanted to--
he was not a destroyer.
He saw himself as a builder.
So maybe in that sense,
something in common
with Steve Jobs as well.
PRESENTER: Question
for you on the brand
that seems so strong
for all of them.
So this is obviously a
time before there was
widespread internet technology.
And a couple of the
ways that you highlight
that they spread
their personal brand
was through and public artwork.
Were there other techniques they
employed to get the word out
and recruit people
to their armies?
BARRY STRAUSS: Yes.
So great question.
Cesar, again, is a really
good example of this,
because he writes these books--
the first campaign
books, if you will--
the commentaries on the
Gallic Wars and commentary
on the Civil War.
And these books are
written as annual reports
that he sends home to Rome.
And they are read
by people in public.
And they are ways to
give certain messages--
one, that Caesar is
really doing great things
for the Roman people, two, that
Caesar is a friend of the Roman
people, and three, that you
don't want to mess with Caesar.
These are the messages that
he's sending home in that way.
Another way in which people
communicate their message
was through religion.
Religion was very
important for all of them.
Hannibal associating
himself with Hercules
before he goes on his
mission of conquest--
he goes to the Temple of
Hercules on the Atlantic Ocean,
and he lets it be
known that he's
in touch with Hercules himself
before he goes on that mission.
He also has visions, and he lets
people know about his dreams
and visions everywhere he goes.
So that is another way
to get the message out.
PRESENTER: So some
of the companies
that we see more and more in the
modern era have a somewhat less
hierarchical structure,
especially in Silicon Valley,
and are considered
more flat, where
anyone can take and should
take leadership initiative.
What comparisons would you
draw between the cultures
that they tried to
intentionally create?
Were they more or
less hierarchical?
Did it depend on the leader?
BARRY STRAUSS: Yeah.
Obviously, there's
a long, long way
from these armies
to Silicon Valley.
But the one way in which I think
there is something similar--
particularly,
again, with Caesar--
is the attempt to reach
outside of the narrow circles
of the senior officers to
find out what should be done.
It was really very unusual
for the commanding officer
to say I want to
take these captains,
and I want them to
be in the meeting
when we decide what to do.
That really is very unusual.
And then to write
books in which he
advertises to people that
he's talking to the captains--
again, that is a very
unusual thing to do.
Caesar's own style
was not particularly
approachable or personable.
But in practice,
in his own way, he
was reaching out to a much
wider group of people.
Likewise, Caesar, in
terms of his advisors,
he's reaching outside of the
usual circle of the Roman
nobility.
He's consulting foreigners,
and he brings them
into his inner
circle, or people who
were foreigners who had been
given the Roman citizenship.
Because Romans did that.
And he makes them some
of his chief advisers.
This is shocking
to traditionalists,
but it is a way in which he's
flattening his organization
just a little bit.
Alexander also is reaching
out to foreigners.
He's horrifying
traditionalists from Macedon
who are saying, hey,
we thought that we
were going to be the rulers.
What does this mean
that you are talking
to people who we've conquered?
And Alexander marries women
among the conquered people.
And that's also a way in which
he's reaching out and shocking
and horrifying his followers.
PRESENTER: Sounds like they
were disruptive for their time.
BARRY STRAUSS: They
were definitely
disruptive for their time.
PRESENTER: One last
question, then.
You mentioned that they had,
obviously, their qualities that
allowed them to inspire
followership, and be
great leaders, and have
very impressive victories
and conquests in
multiethnic armies.
Talk a little bit
about the lessons
that we can derive
from blind spots
and when the victory
goes to the head.
How do you avoid
that as a leader?
BARRY STRAUSS: Well,
the Romans had a custom.
When a leader would
win a great victory,
he would march in a
triumphal procession
through the streets
of Rome in a chariot.
And there would always
be someone behind him
whose job it was to say
to him, remember to die.
Remember you are a mortal.
So I think that one of the
things a leader really needs
is people who can
say that to him,
trustworthy people
who can say you're not
as great as you think you are.
And that's a really
difficult thing to do.
I'd say that each
of these leaders--
the one way in
which they failed is
they all had troubled
relationships with their number
two.
None of them had a number two--
none of them had a really good
relationship with a number two.
And often, that
is the thing that
will save leaders-- to have
someone trustworthy who
can tell them that very thing.
I think that's one of
the problems they have.
PRESENTER: Very fascinating.
Thank you so much.
Please join me in
thanking Barry Strauss
for being here with us today.
And hopefully, we
can all take away
some interesting food for
thought for the rest of our day
here.
BARRY STRAUSS: Thank you.
PRESENTER: Thank you.
BARRY STRAUSS: Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]